how to get massive traffic on a limited
budget i got a great question from one
of my readers robert who wrote in he's
an affiliate network marketer he's part
of the five figure day affiliate program
biggest challenge right now getting
massive traffic to my site unlimited
budget how can you help me what do you
suggest
robert this is important and for
everybody who's watching who's in
network marketing or affiliate marketing
or any kind of venture
the first rule is you have to love what
you're doing and have a story that you
can tell and this is something that
most network marketers and affiliate
marketers fall down on they start
promoting a product because
they think they can make a lot of money
but they have no connection or personal
story to what they're trying to sell
so i don't know about this program what
it's all about
but for you to be successful with this
you have to have a personal story that
means something so when you're telling
people about it if it's on your website
or with a video or twitter whatever it
is it comes from the heart it comes from
a place of really wanting to help people
and it comes from you being able to
share your story
if you can't do that if you're using a
stock website that the company gives you
and you're just dumping this thing out
and trying to get traffic to your site
you're never going to make it you're
never going to have success with it if
you look at the top earners
in network marketing affiliate marketing
they have a personal story that they can
tell about how this product or service
changed their lives and they use it
because people need to connect and
relate to you
before they'll make any decision
there's also tons of guys selling the
same thing
and tons of network and affiliate
marketing opportunities why should they
pick you over anybody else
because they trust you like you know you
believe when you feel like you are
speaking truth to them
so you have to have a personal story and
a personal connection to what you're
selling this relates for any
entrepreneur
usually if you're starting your own
business cell you're creating your own
product or service you have some kind of
connection to it right you're starting
it for a reason out of a frustration or
somebody's come to you asking for help
a lot of times when affiliate network
marketing you're just doing it to try to
make money and the guys who do that
never do anything with it okay
once you've done that
if you do have a story if you do believe
in something then your job is to spread
the message okay come up with one
concept or one word that really defines
what you're all about
and then start sharing content about it
if it's blog posts if it's videos if
it's twitter everything should relate to
that same concept and you'll start to
create a movement
so for my business
i'm all about belief i believe in
entrepreneurs i believe that you need to
believe in what you're doing believe
that you can do it believe that it's
going to work out and everything that i
create on the website on my twitter on
youtube it's all uplifting inspiring
encouraging for entrepreneurs and it's
created this movement around believe
where people are using a hashtag and
people are saying believe on messages
and emailing their friends about it
you have to have something to say
so what do you stand for and what do you
say because i've seen a lot of the guest
posts on affiliate marketing and
different products and most of them are
crap
and it doesn't matter if you get the
best guest blog post on a certain blog
if what you write is not great it
doesn't have a story doesn't speak truth
to somebody doesn't
make them feel
the pain of their current life and see
an option
to escape it by working with you
if that's not real if that's not genuine
then you're never gonna make any sales
through it
so step one is have something
that you actually believe in that you
can tell a story
that's personal deep and meaningful
step two
is create the concept
or one word that you can stand behind
that can create a movement that
everything you talk about is about this
one thought or this one word something
that you fundamentally believe in is one
of your core values
that people can share so when you're
writing something it has a lot of
meaning to it it's not just some crappy
article
once you've done that that's the hard
work
once you figure that out
then you can do all the traditional
strategies you can create content on
your website you can create guest post
content you can create videos you could
do interviews with other people who have
youtube video channels you can do
guest tweeting you could tweet on your
own account
but the message that you're putting out
there is shareable
most of the stuff is garbage
and so nobody shares about it so if you
want traffic coming to your site it has
to be something that people want to read
right
that's the foundation
so when i create a new video or if i
create a new blog post or if i'm working
with a company i'll create something for
their site what i'm speaking is truth
and relates to a movement that i've
helped create and people want to go
there and they want to share it with
their friends and email it and tweet it
and put it on facebook and share it on
youtube
that happens because the message itself
is powerful
so that's your three-step strategy
to drive a massive traffic to your site
and i hope you'll apply it to your
business i know it can be hard i know at
the beginning it's a struggle
and
and we all want tons of traffic right
but you need to get the right traffic
and it comes from having something you
believe in and you stand for and that's
powerful and that will move people and
and that is part of your story and is
deeply personal to you
that's going to drive people to action
and the action will be sharing it or
signing up with you or referring
customers to you
all of the intended desired actions that
you want
will start with the quality of the
content that you're putting in
believe
those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to do more for you and
please leave a comment let me know what
you think let me know what's on your
mind you have a question put it below
i'll make a video response thank you so
much you guys make my week every week i
love you guys and i'll see you soon